skeptics guide to the mind what
neuroscience can and cannot tell us
about ourselves the first two chapters
are about out of body experiences
phantom limbs problems assigning agency
to our own actions and dr. Burton
describes many of the same reports that
you've are trotted out in the scores of
popular books on computation on
neuroscience and the brain more often
than not with some of the unsupported
interpretations that are floating around
about what these this data means he
points out that even reputable
neuroscientists are as quick to fuel the
public appetite for disturbing anecdotes
and attention gate getting sound bytes
what Roberts book helps the reader to do
is to revisit some of the many patient
cases animal studies MRI recordings from
a different perspective offering
alternative explanations and dissecting
the way these results are explained in
the popular press and why so many of
those explanations are misleading
premature and needlessly theatrical
essentially pandering to our high
opinion of our own vaunted brains the
having studied neuroscience for now
about 20 years about 10 years excuse me
that seems and and taught a course at
Stanford I thought I was pretty savvy
about neuroscience and the ability to
parse out the true facts in reading some
of these papers but in several instances
Robert helped me to recognize how I had
allowed language and hyperbole
surrounding the public versions of these
scientific studies to entail insinuates
itself into my scientific view Roberts
new book seeks to exorcise some of these
comfortable and often compelling about
ultimately misleading views of
neuroscience
it's a thoughtful book it's a really
intriguing and fun book to read and I'm
looking forward to what you have to say
today
is that too loud or just right it's okay
because I tend to talk really quickly
I'm from the era where you paid for the
phone by the minute and if you guys have
to leave now this slide sort of is the
main takeaway namely though we don't
like to admit it the tools of
neuroscience are not fMRI scans and
intracellular recordings the primary
tool for studying the mind as opposed to
the brain is the mind itself we dream up
the questions we dream up the
experiments we write the algorithms for
the fMRI we interpret the results and
herein lies problem a which we're not
going to go into any further which is
the polemic of the mind studying itself
what I wanted wanted to talk about today
is to what extent our own brains shape
the way we conceptualize a mine now let
me just start by asking a simple
question how many of you people think
that the brain is the mind okay how many
people think the brain emerges from the
mind how many people think the brain is
other than those one of the first two
possibilities okay so what it amounts to
is as soon as you ask that question what
you realize is what is a mind I mean if
the mind is not a synapse it's not a
neuron it's not something that you go
away measure feel pet stroke talk ask
questions - okay so what I really want
to do is talk about the brain as it
generates some of our concepts of the
mind and maybe to just alter if possible
the ways we think about a mind not I'm
not gonna give you any answers if you
think I know what the mind is the doors
open so but before we do that I want to
concede one thing to Google and at the
same time it will sort of be the
background of this talk this is
something I heard yesterday
and was someone in the locker room where
I workout he said and I said that in
with a perfectly straight face there's
so much information that trouble keeping
up with reality and there's a what makes
us funny if it to me is that you're
confusing two concepts fact with reality
and reality is a philosophical
metaphysical conundrum it's not a
scientific fact unless you believe that
fact that that everything is objective
and that's it in which case you're still
stuck with what are abstract ideas and
so on but the difference is you have
facts at one level and you have ideas at
another level and the real question in
going from the brain and mine is can you
bridge that gap so a second of
background I'm so old that I started in
here what people believed in mind-body
dualism when I was a neurology resident
when the questions you were commonly
called on that to solve is does is a
patient's problem psychiatric or
neurologic as though there was a
difference now we've gone 40 years down
the road and the technologies obviously
spectacular compared to when I first
started out but there's an inherent
underlying problem one has to translate
neuroscience into a language that's
comprehensible it doesn't mean anything
to say that synapses are firing at X
rate you have to know what that means in
terms of experience you have to have a
language for interpretation but the
language ironically of neuroscience is
the language of popular culture a
psychology philosophy movies etcetera so
in other words when people started an
experiment so I'm going to study
altruism okay that's a great idea but
everybody has a different idea of
altruism some people think it's
self-serving and other people think it's
self-sacrificing but the concept of
altruism is not
written in stone somewhere where you can
study it get adequate data and suddenly
say that data represents an objective
fact at the level of the of the
definition so the circular arrows I have
there are because there's got there has
become a peculiar recursive phenomena as
philosophy wants desperately keep up
with science it takes the facts of
neuroscience and as neuroscience tries
to explain neuroscience to the
philosophers they used the language of
philosophy so you see all these books
now on free will for example well free
will is not is not a scientific piece of
information it is a concept that
originally arose out of a theological so
I was just talking about Tom a minute
ago and we end about the computational
aspects of the brain so let's take the
picture on the left which allegedly is a
is a sort of reconstructed
three-dimensional picture of a pain
matrix now imagine that you have someone
who tells you that their toe hurts and
you have that picture you say well this
corresponds with the person's subjective
phenomena now supposing you have the
same picture and they tell you they
don't have any subjective phenomena
questions how do you interpret that and
now there are loads of studies on
so-called neural correlates of pain
including an unconscious animals now you
get into a real philosophical
psychological or a metaphysical
conundrum of what is unconscious pain so
if you believe that this report is is
the neural correlate of pain what does
it mean if you see that in someone who
says they don't have pain so there are
some obviously some major issues that
have arisen in talking about different
levels and it's created and some
fabulous nonsense
and I'll just let let you look through
these real quickly these are all
gathered from good journals these are
not from garbage journals okay how about
that one what does it mean to have a
site for free will at this one I saw
this morning and here again is the
problem unrealistic optimism in the face
of reality was in nature neuroscience
article this morning or fMRI proves that
pain is real I mean what else would it
be but then it gets into the definition
of what is real this is one where they
showed a number of women some
pornographic pictures and they weren't
aroused and they found in an area that
brain didn't light up it like it should
other women who were aroused and
therefore the conclusion that the pain
that libido problems were in the brain
not the mind and I'm going this is a
misunderstanding of the difference
between the brain and mind I thought
maybe there people having a bad hair day
or something and I mean the I reasons
are infinite but the interpretation is
reductionist this one was particularly
spectacular that the suggestion was that
sense you can demonstrate neural
pathways or or
berries a brain that light up for
courage
the theory is well maybe we can
stimulate courage through transcranial
magnetic stimulation but the one that
really stopped me was a couple weeks ago
this one came out now does anybody think
that a baby five months old doesn't have
memory and consciousness you know as
Francis Crick once said as as study not
worth doing is not worth doing well and
but nevertheless this is what happens
when you're trying to prove something
beyond the area of data if they had said
we have seen a certain neural activity
associated babies at this level of
neural development hey that's great
data is data the interpretation is
storytelling which is really going to be
the punchline of my little talk today
but it's not just humorous it's changing
our attitude in ways that are
fundamental and kind of alarming so I
want to actually present a clinical case
to you folks and ask you to make the
diagnosis and as you do sort of think
about why you came up with the ideas
that you did keep in mind that one of
the real advantages of the Oliver Sacks
method of neurology is in observing the
patient and talking to them and kind of
get the steps that lead up to whatever
idea or that emerges so the case was
very simple was a young twenty five year
old woman who was in a massive
automobile accident unfortunately a
devastating brain damage she was left in
what's called a persistent vegetative
state she would open her eyes but did
not look around and register didn't
respond had normal voice leave cycles
but essentially had no response to her
outside environment and the regular MRI
scan showed massive areas of brain
damage but not all of her cortex was
there were preserved areas of cortex and
other areas that would greatly damage
well the researchers did a wonderful
technologically sophisticated study they
put a it would headphones on her put her
inside an fMRI scanner and asked her to
questions one can you imagine walking
around your house and number two can you
imagine playing tennis and she'd been an
avid tennis player before now they then
compared
her fMRI scan to normal controls and
they were quite similar given variances
of fMRI they were basically the same so
her brain lit up the same way as normal
healthy controls how many of you people
would think that she's therefore
conscious
now let me say that that she's still
lying there unresponsive and now what
we're left with is a definition of
consciousness and how do you figure out
what represents conscious now I'm going
to put aside that consciousness can be a
variety of states from nightmare to
delirium to confusion to the kind of
confusion you have when you first awaken
in the morning but you're still awake
and conscious but you you know you're
you're fuzzy in the head so there are
lots of subjective states of
consciousness not just one it's not
binary and there's also the problem of
arousal but put that aside for the
moment and then so you start to think
about well how much can your brain do
unconsciously versus when you know that
was consciously done so there are two
aspects of that question the first is we
know that if you're at a cocktail party
and you hear your name mentioned even
though you weren't listening suddenly
you become aware of a conversation that
you hadn't heard earlier well they've
done lots of studies that have shown
that you can process auditory and visual
information even when you're
unresponsive for example on the lower
end of the scale when when mothers are
sleeping and you present a bunch of
names to them nothing happens to present
the name of their child even though they
don't wake up there EEG changes you can
present people in coma visual
representations of their family and they
they're their brains in cortical areas
that are lower levels than to total
cortical area will light up so what
you're left with is a fundamental
question that has not yet been answered
I'm not even sure as addressable but it
certainly hasn't been answered is how
much of our thought is conscious and how
much of our thought actually is
unconscious then the question arises in
this day and age what would you say to
the family so here's what the authors
said in their article and said to the
family
and my question is is that the correct
approach to modern neuroscience what
would that be how many people would vote
that that is the what they should tell
the family wouldn't it make more sense
to say we see that she's still
clinically unresponsive statistics in
this group of patients is that the
recovery is relatively limited we but on
the other hand we have this new
information and it may shed additional
light on this and we need to follow this
up we need more we need to consider this
but then what you realize is what we're
really down to is again problem of
definition so let me ask you a question
how many people in this room think you
have complex conscious thought okay so
let me just try and dissuade you of that
one the average average person even at
Google so average for Google which maybe
you shift the Belser curve over 50 IQ
points whatever still can only remember
seven to nine digits still if you take a
complex telephone number you chunk it
into area code prefix suffix etc we can
only remember about four chunks of
information at one time at one time and
that lasts for a minute or two so-called
short-term or working memory that's all
you can do consciously you have the RAM
of the first computers ever made and I
mean Edie bitty now if you have a trying
to do a complex thought that involves
let's say myriad factors let's say like
global climate change now you come up
with four or five factors like you're
going to invest in Greenland you know
or the roll the polar bear or whatever
then suddenly somebody gives you another
set of five
you can't keep those five in along with
the other four so yeah it's like heaven
where they call us at Japan or at your
sketch where you have to erase or store
that memory in order to put more in your
so your random X next memory of
short-term memory once it's in your
unconscious is subject to every single
bias that your unconscious brain has and
you don't need to for me to tell you
that that's the subject of everything
Daniel Kahneman's books to mean it's
everywhere way our understanding the the
biases of the unconscious so what it
amounts to once you're down in outside
of awareness if a blue jay flies over
here it may change my idea about what is
global warming for example okay now let
me ask the same question again how many
you people believe in complex conscious
thought it doesn't change anything what
I tell you and that's really why I
wanted to so this is what the rest of
this is gonna be about some is wrong
because we know we all feel that it's
okay so some years ago I wrote a book
five years ago book called on being
certain and in it what I finally
realized is that in addition to having
the computational skills of your of your
brain your brain has to notify yourself
what's going on outside of awareness so
you take for example I look at it faces
now I don't recognize most of you but I
recognize that you're all people I mean
that that meant or mostly
that's a pattern recognition that's
going unconsciously but I don't have any
sense of recognition but if I recognize
somebody sitting in the front row let's
say I will also my brain if it wants to
draw attention to it will say that's
Peter Norvig let's say so you if you
think about it we have systems for
understanding ourselves in our
environment that's you know sight sound
so on we have somatic sensations for the
external world
we have visceral sensations for internal
world but we obviously must have some
kind of subjective sensation for what
goes on computationally it just doesn't
go on it's it it goes on in silence the
computation but then you have to be
notified if there's a 3% chance that I
recognize someone in the audience maybe
it doesn't reach the threshold I don't
notice it it reaches 60% is a
computation not only do you get the
computation but you get a message the
message says I recognize that person and
then at 100% you say that's absolutely
Joe Blow in the same kind of idea goes
for a thought if you have a hunch and
it's such a low-level hunt you don't pay
attention to it then you say oh that
might be right you know and that's worth
pursuing om - an aha which is an
absolute certainty but nobody here can
generate an aha
and aha happens to you it is a sensation
it is the same thing as an itch or a
pain only as a glorious sensation so
what it finally occurred to me is that
we have a number involuntary mental
sensations that generate much of what we
experience as a mind let's put aside
emotions and moods and the small amount
of sort of memory that we can have in
random-access so but when I asked you
the question about how many people think
you still have complex conscious thought
the question is why because we
experience it we're so we're having an
experience so let me ask you put it
another way what if you have you go you
go to bed at night and you're trying to
remember Charlie Brown's name you can't
remember
wake up in the morning and you remember
it and you say it just occurred to me it
popped into my mind whatever you say you
have no sensation of thinking is that
correct it just occurs you that's why
people talk about muses and so on but if
you try really hard to remember charlie
brown's name you have a sense of effort
you have a sense that you're thinking
about it so the real question is is your
brain working differently under those
two circumstances and how would you know
it seems unlikely that your heart beats
differently when you feel it beating it
and when you don't by the same token it
seems unlikely your brain would have a
mechanism where it switches back and
forth of you're aware of it it works in
one way and if you're not aware of it it
works completely differently
so what's the difference the difference
is the way you feel about it so if
you're trying to study a really hard
calculus problem and you you you feel
like you're putting a lot of effort into
it so you say I study really hard I
thought really hard about that but
supposing you wake up in the morning
with the answer to that problem you
don't have any sense of effort at all
none so if you go back to the diagram
previously about little small nubbin of
purely conscious thought but it's all we
experienced that's how we think we all
have conscious complex thought
irrespective of what you might surmise
from the data okay and my one point is
they are different there's a sensory
foot there in the sensory phenomena and
they're the computations it just as an
aside for those people are of the old
school and study the Chinese box
experiment about whether a eye has
whether the computer can really
understand is a confusion about the
demonstrating computation and sensation
computers do really great at whatever
they understood whatever they do it's in
the semantics of understanding that they
don't have the sensory phenomena that
gives us a sense of understanding but
they may come up with the same net
result they may it may well surpass it
so you have two aspects if you think
about AI that's computation if they
think that the future of AI if you want
to make
robots that are human beings they'll
have to figure out how to to figure out
what the sensory phenomena are and
that's really the hard problem of
consciousness whether we can ever get
there you can debate about it but unless
you're clairvoyant I can't tell you
which is more likely so if you think
about it it's not just pattern
recognition equals recognition sensation
but they're a whole host of sensations
feeling and knowing I just mentioned but
I'd like to just start with something
that we all know but kind of deny we
have physical dimensions of a sense of
self if I for example if I stimulate
certain area the brain I can create
out-of-body sensations if this can
happen but people with brain tumors with
certain forms of epilepsy what it
amounts to though is we can actually
with virtual reality shift one's own
personal sense of self if you take
because our sense of self comes from our
eyes we in terms of where we think we're
located so if you look out at the world
you sing it from wherever the
perspective you're now if I put a
virtual reality apparatus on your eyes
but then have the cameras start from a
different position like from the vantage
point of a nearby mannequin people will
feel that they are located inside the
mannequin and then you can come up to
that mannequin with a knife and try and
stab the mannequin and the person will
actually experience increased heart rate
sweating and feeling of anxiety because
he actually even though he knows
cognitively that that's not him
he can't control the feeling that he's
actually inside the mannequin so these
body swap illusion is clearly telling
you that the brain creates a physical
sense of self is involuntary sensation
also creates a sense of ownership and by
ownership I mean if you if you raise
your arm like this you feel like it
you've done it voluntarily and that it's
your arm if you go to a doctor's office
and he raises your arm it's still your
arm but you no longer feel you did it
yourself we have a very good body heart
recognition
if we have good recognition for our body
parts then we also have a sense of
ownership of our mind it's my money and
these are my thoughts we can't get away
from the fact that when you have a
thought we thought we thought it because
of the feelings we have can a feeling
that since we have a sense of agency
that we generated the thought and then a
sense of agency is part of what makes
thought a feel like it generates thought
B now it's it's hard to say this and and
fully accept this because all we
experience is thought a causes flood B
so even while I'm talking to you here I
believe that I'm making some clever set
of sentences following in a linear
fashion but if you think about it the
brain works in parallel if myriad things
going on simultaneously so mic sensation
of a linear thought may actually be a
misrepresentation in what is occurring
at an unconscious level but let me go on
so you if you have a sense of ownership
of your body parts in a constrained
physical self
they've even shown for example that if
you have damage to your amygdala it will
change how close you can get to other
people if you have damage to your
amygdala instead of our normal
interpersonal distance or other people's
a few feet people who have these damaged
they have no sense of restriction
similarly there are kids with Williams
syndrome which is a genetic disorder
with us and they don't have a sense of
distance so we have sense of a body
involuntarily generated sense of self
distance from other people sense of
agency sense of body ownership sense of
that we're thinking agency choice and
causation and I go into some loved
detail you really have time today to go
to basically these constitute the
cognitive mental sensations that make up
what we experience when we're thinking
and the fundamental paradox is that
these involuntary
mechanism to give you a sense of a
unique willful self in action thinking
making deliberate choices determining
causation now this is hard to swallow in
it at first glance cuz it goes against
everything we believe as rational man
but the evidence is in my is really
staggering so is at least worth
considering so if you think about it
what do we experience when we're when we
experience thoughts from the standpoint
of I thought I mentioned we have
perceptions we have emotions and moods
that's it and that is the tool that is
studying the mind that is the mind
that's trying to study itself and if you
think about it from a standpoint that
you're driving down the road of life we
have what you might think of as a mental
dashboard
some people are boring skeptics like
myself and other people are know-it-alls
who seem like they have the answer for
everything and we can argue about all
the personality traits that might go
into the difference but the fact of the
matter is I don't get very often a
feeling of knowing I know that even when
I write this book and I think oh isn't
this clever I pick it up the next day
and I say is that right I mean there's
there's something elusive about that
feeling of understanding that I don't
particularly have other people I'm sure
you've heard and stand up here and say
this is the way it is they with
dogmatically say there isn't any other
possibility and we've always attributed
that to psychological maladies and
arrogance and so on but the fact of the
matter is it may well be at least in
part if if not primarily because of a
different tweaking of how strongly your
mental sensations of different various
varieties I mentioned come into play now
you can think of this in for another
standpoint you think of optimism
pessimism risk reward some people are
risk averse if other people are not and
if you take the studies on identical
twins raised apart
you find out is that a good percentage
over 50% of the character traits are
shared irrespective of no environment so
it's nature plus nurture but it can
there's a considerable degree of sharing
of personality traits if you consider
these involuntary mental sensations as a
another form of personality traits you
start to see get a picture for how each
of us is comprised of different senses
of agency or feelings of causation for
example somebody takes melatonin and
goes to sleep they wake in the morning
soon I got this new wonder drug it
occurs sleeplessness someone else's I
took melatonin I went to sleep I don't
know if they're related and you always
think well the guy that made a
conclusion based on an end of one is an
idiot but it's not doesn't work quite
like that they actually have that very
strong feeling that's how that's of
causation that a led to be led to see
where someone else doesn't have it so if
you think about people in general each
one of us is a mixture of all of these
various traits in different proportions
if you imagine we have dials or
different settings we're all different
and it explains some of the enormous
comp difficulty in communication with
each other because you have to be at the
same level on a certain thing I mean if
you take a know-it-all on the skeptic
giving you think they have nothing to
talk about
they just can't communicate so if you
think about these involuntary mental
sensations you come up with another way
of thinking about a lot of different
kinds of mental illness also for example
in people with obsessive-compulsive
disorder they turn off the gas and they
walk out the door sit whoops I don't
sure he turned off the gas so they come
back to the room turn off the gas again
in the stove you know do it 4 or 5 times
10 times 20 times they can never be
satisfied that the gas is turned off you
say to them look it's off the dial is
off there's no and they can't stop and
what you realize is that they have no
sensation of no
whatsoever they can't know it even
though at the level of feeling they know
it at the level of cognition and it's
this discrepancy that you see in so many
so-called mental disorders you see in
the opposite in people with delusional
states that are convinced that
something's wrong and or that the
Martians have tapped into their Wi-Fi
yet it's very hard to dissuade them
because it's a feeling of on the other
end extreme of feeling of certainty but
even the so body schema image disorders
which we sort of understand but we kind
of attributed psychological factors
whether or not that's true or not it may
well be true that law the bottom line is
it ends up as a problem of your
representational map for example a
couple of weeks ago they showed an
interesting study that if I walk through
a doorway when it is only 25% wider and
I'm I will start to turn sideways just
to avoid bumping into something but
people's anorexia do this when it's
between 40 and 50 percent wider they
actually see themselves as bigger and I
was talking to a woman recently who were
very attrex surgeon she said you can
take the weight off but you can't change
the body image so what you start to see
is feelings about the self it said are
deeply ingrained and they are the
starting point for thinking of the mind
as an experience now as we go forward in
neuroscience we will the brain will
become and progressively unravel when
your minds unraveling for different
reasons but I mean that knowledge about
the brain but as concept is whatever we
think about the mind is generated by
these experiences that's the stuff that
is part of the fundamental problem
that's why I showed the first slide of
the mind trying to conceive of itself
because we got involuntary aspects of
brain function that are shaping the very
way we think about the mind no I want to
give to give you an exact Wieck example
when I asked you the question before it
is the brain you know is it mine just
the brain it emerged from the brain
most people feel that it's one or the
other and I think only a couple people
raise their hand saying that it's more
than the brain now it's true that
everything we do emanates ultimately
from the brain but if you think about
information where it comes from
perhaps it's greater than the brain how
would you know that so let me just
present one of my curiosity speculations
now I'm I don't know how many people
realize this but slime mold loves oak
brand and two wonderful studies have
been done one in which you take oat bran
and you paste it on the major cities in
England and the slime mold which has no
nervous system whatsoever will merge
together from individual little cells
into a multinucleated single giant
organism and it will seek out the oat
bran in a way that's the most efficient
so they take a topographic map of
England and slime mold recreates the
British highway system and they've done
this for Japan same thing they put it on
the major cities and it recreates the
railway system so they ask the one who
did the Japanese study what does this
mean slime molds intelligent I mean they
have no no nervous system whatsoever and
the man said that the researcher said
depends what you mean by intelligence
but he said from a mathematical
standpoint it's approximately the same
degree of complexity is a person
learning to ride a bicycle same degree
of complexity is in the cerebellum is
riding a bicycle so let me present my
second example of what I'd like to do at
least consider the in the 20s was
thought there were two types of locusts
solitary locust and in an academic
jargon they were considered to garius if
they swarmed and solitary locusts are
vegetarian they live by themselves
they're very finicky eaters and normally
live lives like that however if they get
into a circumstance such as in Africa
rains they breed like crazy and then the
rain goes away now there are a lot of
locusts and there no water the locust
changes to the so called swarming locust
you've all seen pictures of them by the
million and the first thing they start
to do or they make these little marching
movements with their feet and then they
then they start eating each other eating
everything in sight they're voracious
users actually become cannibals what's
interesting to me is that their brain
changes their visual cortex changes from
being primarily optimized for solitaire
acquisition of food to group hunting so
for group acquisition of food so the
entire cortex changes its higher is
hierarchy visual cortex they their
muscles in their legs change there's 30%
a more muscle bulk that color changes
etc well it turned out about 10 years
ago that that their little hairs on the
back of locus and you stroke them
neighborly serotonin and the serotonin
levels in the brain dramatically
elevated when you do this when and so
they found that this happens when they
get to a certain critical density and
enclosures and you can completely block
the swarming effect by blocking
serotonin in the brain so here you have
animals that their brain changes in
their group context yes these the the
impetus starts with the individual body
but it's a part of a group phenomena
won't occur on its own now I don't know
how many of you people have been in a
rock concert or something and when
you're leaving you know there are a
bunch of people you start going like
this sort of not to hit the guy in front
of you you say I'm doing this not to
walk into the guy in front of me well
there's no way to know whether you're
doing it for that reason or this is a
group phenomena that occurs it at a rock
contest now I don't really care about
what this means
personally it you know in terms of that
walking but it tells you something about
the feelings of agency dictate how we
think about the mine in terms of even
doing the study
we do if we want to study empathy you
put a solitary person in an fMRI scan
you give them an empathy questionnaire
or you show a video but what if empathy
is a group phenomenon you'd never see it
in an fMRI scan of one person
now imagine to me one of the most owners
things of the 20th century was the
Nuremberg rallies people on their own
act one within a group that quite
different and you say oh they're making
choices well we don't know that and we
don't know how to study that with
present-day neuroscience whether in the
future that's possible would depend on a
massive increase in technology but I
mentioned this because the way we think
about ourselves as individuals and how
we conceptualize the mind as being
restricted to that little thing behind
your forehead is determined by
mechanisms in your brain not by any
fundamental higher-level reality and it
impairs how we actually think about who
we are both as individuals and as a
society and you know I one of the things
that that is always struck me is the
sense of uniqueness has particularly
extended to our Treatment of Animals
I know as when I was in medical school
they they told us we should take out the
pancreas of a stray dog so we could
watch how it suffered when it died from
diabetes and nobody even consider the
fact that they were taking a dog and
doing it I still have nightmares about
that I mean even today though some of
the best neuroscientists people that I
really respect are writing books about
the science behind what makes us unique
now we think we're unique because we
have these feelings of uniqueness so its
ironically it's our biology it dictates
our sense of uniqueness the feel it
tells us that where you need but hey
that's no different than what Sarah
Palin says it's the same argument and
certainly at some point we should start
to consider what these involuntary
sensations mean towards our public
policy etc you know
on that note let me just say that five
years ago I gave you talk on my last
block and I showed this slide and I sort
of smugly said you know this is an
example of how we feel that the top
slide is longer than the bottom slide
and I say this is an example of how we
have a feeling of knowing which is
involuntary even if I tell you the slide
the deep the two lengths are the same we
still feel the other one so it's a
feeling of knowing is at odds with our
cognitive understanding
I thought with net clever but what I
didn't realize is that this isn't just a
matter of our brains in the abstract
they've done studies now which came out
with a year to go that they gave the
same pictures to different kinds of
cultures from the West so-called Western
technology highly edited kids educated
kids who to tribes in Africa tribes in
Africa don't see a difference they see
no illusion here whatsoever and they
tried this with other things and the
conclusion of the authors is that
something is basic as our visual
perception can be changed by our culture
so you go back you think about the locus
do you think but is used to go we need
to rethink how neuroscience thinks about
the minds not the brain you could study
the brain without I mean that's that's
your science so I just leave some time
for questions I want to emphasize the
study the brain is pure science I have
no qualms with that whatsoever and
there's no other way of studying the
world for the point of view of facts but
conclusions about what the mind is or
storytelling I can give you an argument
that that we have a group mind I can
tell you that it's we don't have one but
I don't have any evidence to support
that that's pure speculation I can tell
you we're unique we're not unique I
could tell you we're studying altruism
those are stories that you're telling
based upon the data and so
from my point of view the science of the
mind is one set of stories among many
science uses data stories use clot and
character no no I want to share
something with you how many people think
we all know what this lovely young lady
is thinking through neuroscience I mean
wouldn't it be great to be a mind reader
to know what animals are think but the
fact the matter is if you realize that
we have to have perfect understanding
what's going on in her brain and then
she's got to be able to tell us so but
there are other ways I want I in in
writing my books you know I've been kind
of ignorant of what came before me and I
thought I've closed with this Aristotle
said our desires Harbor a hidden
judgment that their ends are good
basically 2500 years ago he was telling
us that our unconscious mind also has is
making unconscious judgments such as the
feeling of knowing and Dostoevsky was
commenting on conscious versus
unconscious thought soon he sank into
deep thought more completely or more
accurately speaking into a complete
blankness of mind I mean this was
written in the 1860s and for those of
you who'd like to debate the freewill
issue I mean I think Tolstoy summed this
up you say I'm not free but I've raised
and lowered my arm everybody understands
that this llll logical answer is
irrefutable proof of freedom I mean he
understands the paradoxical nature of
any discussion about free will and as
far as called group mine golly with
Charl blue cows Keys idea if you could
separate what the public thinks from
reality that's all you need to know to
bet wisely and I think this is the state
of neuroscience at present so I will I
will now answer questions or look stupid
as best I can
if you could take that slider that had
that sense of certainty about and adjust
it for you just once you only have one
opportunity to do this how would you do
it would you be more sure of your of
your inferences or less sure what most
surely more sure of your inferences and
your thoughts and the ideas that you
come up with or less well you know I
think that if you don't have some sense
of certainty at least to the extent of
feeling you've got a hunch you're never
going to do anything you're not going to
write a novel like I've written several
novels you're going to have to think I'm
on the right track but you can't have so
much certainty that you think you the
character has to do a or b and can't do
C D or F you follow me so you it's it's
you need an you need in it the middle
road how's that that's a simple way of
putting it I I know I think you I think
you have to wear two hats you wear an
editor and a non editor hat in other
words when I'm when I'm writing fiction
I'd say let the is leave the editor at
home try everything and then I'm gonna
go back and visit with my editors hat on
and see if it makes sense so I take know
certainty as the the default position
for trying to create ideas and then as
much as I can do certainty to try and
dissuade
just prove actually what I've written
no I want I want to put it yeah I want
to put it on on off for a while and then
go back and reach for it if I can yeah
but you can't do that either I know that
you asked a tough question they all you
guys all do this so go ahead hey what is
your attitude towards the unknown for
which we don't have the tools currently
to understand within a scientific
framework couple things one is that if I
had any answer for you I would be
clairvoyant by very definition those
people say I think in 50 years or 20
years or 10 years or next week or
sometime we're going to understand the
mind they're they're making a prediction
based upon clairvoyance not facts and if
I told you we weren't I would also be
basing it on no facts so now what so
basically I'm just I'm speculating my
own feeling is that it's that there's
certain insurmountable metaphysical
questions that even if we were to get
great understanding the brain which I
have no doubt that down the road the
techniques will be such that we won't
this will look like primitive man okay
but really what it amounts to is can we
bridge that into the subjective
description notice for example let's say
your foot hurts and I foot hurts but we
have whole different backgrounds for
whatever reason we would need to have
perfect information about each of us for
our entire lives not just for this
instant and then we would have to have
the same language but even if we had the
same language like I you I worked at a
pain clinic at UCSF where people would
say that pain was a ten but their 10
isn't the same as your 10 so you have
the problem you know if qualia are as
your red the same as my red now do I
think you can solve those I like the
idea of mystery I know it's not going to
solve in my lifetime so I enjoy the idea
of mystery but I love the idea of
discovery now so it's sort of sort of
like extended foreplay this is not
exactly a perfect acute is a
curiosity and appreciation for mystery
yeah if you if you you know if you get
to my age and you see the history of
science sort of unfold in front of your
own eyes during your lifetime we've made
a zillion mistakes now to think that
somewhere down the road we won't make
them is to misunderstand the nature of
human beings science works in little
steps little increments forwards steps
backwards sideways with the idea of
moving inexorably towards moving in X
early but not towards any final
conclusion now if that's that's but
that's speculation and that's a novelist
looking at the fact that I like the idea
there multiple explanations at the
beginning you showed a picture of the
brain studying the brain and I think
that this is kind of part of a trend of
looking more at the history and and
further back in the process of what
we're doing so just acknowledging the
fact that you know we have these brains
that have flaws and that's what we're
using to do it and then kind of the next
step that I think about is using
evolution so thinking about the evolved
brain studying the brain but I'm kind of
a skeptic towards evolutionary
psychology I guess you might be someone
as well do you have any hope for
bringing evolution to this picture more
more so than just kind of the sort of
very simple things like say the size of
the visual cortex but more complicated
things like ability to do certain kinds
of computation or things like that well
couple things first of all evolution
happened but evolution isn't an entity
with an agenda I mean so lots of I mean
I don't know how many of you people know
Stephen Jay Gould and that concept of
spandrels but it's worth reading about
but we assign we assign purpose to
everything but without any knowledge at
that so so as far as computational
ability I mean if we're going to survive
I think it's more important that we
develop empathy and compassion and
getting along with others and
computational ability because
unfortunately my
my concern which is probably why I've
written these books is that we will get
smarter we will get more and whatever
tools we can get personally I mean let's
face it you guys are evolution if you
have a PDA or a you can a flash drive
you can down I mean when I was a
neurologist if you could just memorize
all the diseases and where you could
walk around and spout the latest
literature you were genius now you don't
have to do any of that so in a way that
is evolution it's a different kind of
evolution but it isn't it isn't making
us any better it isn't solve any
problems in Congress or climate change
or anything so if I want to say I think
that before we worry about computational
improvements in the individual we will
have them as a group mind extended mind
but I don't know that that's terribly
helpful for what really counts is which
is to understand that we're fallible and
that we have to be a bit humble that
each of our ideas comes from an
idiosyncratic and often the irrational
place even though it may be the best we
can do with science we we are meant in a
science but we still have a lot of
inbuilt biases now that's just a
personal sermon not a not a scientific
comment hi I wonder if you can talk
about the connection connections between
Capgras syndrome
and consciousness and whether there are
we can describe such a thing as defects
of consciousness
let me there are a whole bunch of
so-called dissolute delusional
misidentification syndromes and actually
it's in my first book I cover this at
some length because what really is of
interest now I'll give you an example
because maybe I mean if you guys have
time to stick around quick
is I had a patient many years ago who
had very very very very very small
stroke and was recovered within a few
hours it was funny but who's an art
dealer and he phoned me up when he got
home he said something Horrible's
happened I said what's that he says my
my desk has been replaced by an
imitation and what he had was a 12 foot
refectory desk a refectory table that
you would you'd have to take the doors
off to get it out so it was pretty
obvious that it hadn't
place and he understood that but when he
ran his hand across the the tabletop he
said yes those are the wormholes was
nante those are the wormholes and those
are the scuff marks in everything
they're exactly like before but they
don't feel familiar they don't feel like
they used to
I said well they're the same size and
yeah he was total agreement as to the
cognitive aspects of that desk but he
could not convince himself that it
wasn't imitation because they didn't
feel familiar in that case was one of
the ones that started me to think about
the discrepancy between understanding a
cognitive understanding he could he
could draw you know he understood what
that was a desk but he couldn't grasp
that it was his and so basically that
sensation is that is you say with
consciousness consciousness for him was
a combination of the intellectual
knowledge came as a fact and the feeling
so yes though Capgras syndrome those and
those delusions are a form of disorders
of involuntary mental states which are
reflected in consciousness if that
answers your question well more
specifically do you think that we can
understand consciousness as a sort of
continuum that can be degraded you can
measure the level of degradation based
on certain defects oh there's no
question if it's like a doubt that its
consciousness goes like that if that's
what you mean yes and and you're aware
of this and at the periphery and then it
drops off and I suppose all of these are
elements yes if you if you add them all
together you'd have a better idea what
consciousness is so I just reminded your
question on this mind versus brain so so
there in Buddhism that is this Buddha
had this that is a story about Buddha
there were 14 questions if I remember
correctly that he was never ready to
make any answer about so but one of them
was something like I think these three
questions were exactly among these 14
questions that would have was never so
when he was asked this question that if
didn't say anything so I just wanted
that there your attitude is more like is
something that is not it's not
meaningful question or is it something
that so that it's inherently a stupid
question or is it something that may be
answered in the future there are
different kinds of questions there's
some that that are meaningful but seem
like they're very difficult I mean
obviously it's meaningful to ask what is
consciousness
okay on the other hand to ask what is
free will is a different kind of
question because it to me free will the
very question first of all the word free
will doesn't make sense because what
other kind of will would there be and
you think well how is it that everybody
writes books on free will without even
saying what does that word mean then if
you go back and think about it from a
historical perspective you know it was
really pounded into the public mind by
Augustine you're 300 now why is it at
twenty eighteen hundred years later
we're still debating it when they after
eight you haven't got an answer so to me
one possibility is maybe the question
makes no sense but then it gets down to
how you think about determinism in
various levels of the determinism versus
emergent behavior and then you get guys
standing here talking about
compatibilism which makes no sense but
what it amounts to the original question
doesn't in for example what came before
the beginning well that's a language
question it's like Wittgenstein once
said it is after noon on the Sun no I
mean you have to laugh when you hear
that you go that's a great sentence I
mean it we should learn from those kind
of nonsense things and and you know this
book how something comes from nothing
you know all the latest is well that
again is an attempt to distort a paradox
right so there are those questions that
are really meaningful that are really
hard to grasp like how does the brain
create subjective response and there are
others they're just like huh why bother
to ask that question so it runs the
gamut but that's my cynicism that's our
skepticism that cynicism they're closely
alive